dibuja un rectángulo con la misma área
que el rectángulo dado pero con
diferentes medidas de sus lados y por
aquí tenemos el rectángulo dado y
queremos dibujar otro rectángulo con la
misma área eso es muy importante
misma área pero con diferentes medidas
de sus lados y bueno recuerda que es el
área el área es el espacio que cubre una
figura entonces lo que queremos saber es
cuántas unidades cubre este rectángulo
de aquí o cuál es su área ahora bien si
cada pequeño cuadrado es una unidad
cuadrada entonces observa que tenemos 12
7-8 pequeños cuadrados es decir ocho
unidades cuadradas cubren a mi
rectángulo o dicho de otra manera este
rectángulo tiene un área de ocho
unidades cuadradas así que queremos
dibujar otro rectángulo que también
cubra ocho unidades cuadradas porque si
cubren ocho unidades cuadradas entonces
tendrán un área de ocho unidades
cuadradas pero además nos piden que
tengan diferentes medidas de sus lados
así que primero vamos a ver cuáles son
las medidas de los lados de este
rectángulo que tengo aquí y si observas
aquí en la izquierda tenemos una unidad
mientras que aquí arriba tenemos ocho
unidades en sus lados y por eso tenemos
un área de ocho unidades cuadradas así
que este rectángulo de ocho unidades
cuadradas lo podemos descomponer en una
fila en una fila
en ocho unidades cuadradas muy bien
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es pensar
en otra forma de crear un rectángulo que
tenga también ocho unidades cuadradas
con diferentes formas de descomponerlo y
una idea que se me ocurre es pensar en
dos filas en dos filas de bueno serán
cuatro unidades cuadradas porque así voy
a tener ocho unidades cuadradas dos
filas de cuatro unidades cuadradas
también cumplen ocho unidades cuadradas
así que vamos a intentarlo vamos a ver
si empiezo aquí entonces dos filas de
cuatro de lujo dos filas de cuatro y
ahora vamos a poner el ecuador para que
veas que este de aquí también va a tener
un área de ocho unidades cuadradas y lo
podemos ver justo aquí tenemos una 2
4 5 6 7 8 unidades cuadradas eso quiere
decir que el rectángulo original y ahora
este nuevo rectángulo tienen un área de
ocho unidades cuadradas tienen la misma
área porque ambos cubren la misma
cantidad de espacio pero ambos tienen
diferentes medidas de sus lados que es
justo lo que nos piden aquí este nuevo
un rectángulo que acabamos de hacer
tienen en el lado izquierdo un lado de
dos unidades y en la parte superior
tiene un lado de cuatro unidades así que
ya tenemos nuevos lados y esta es una
forma en la que podemos dibujar un
rectángulo con la misma área pero con
diferentes medidas de sus lados